[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
يعاد حديثها فيزيد حسنا وقد يستقبح الشيء
المعاد السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
والغفران ولكن عندما نقرا قوله تعالى في
سوره البقره
ويسالونك ماذا ينفقون اولي العفو كذلك
يبين الله لكم الايات لعلكم تتفكرون
المعنى هنا الزياده التي تفيض عن حاجه
الشخص ومعاشه يسالونك يا محمد ماذا ينفقون
في التبرع والصدقه قل لهم انفقوا القدر
الذي يزيد على حاجتكم
عندما نقرا كلمه قاموا يتباذر الى الذهن
معنى القيام والنهوض ولكن نقرا قوله تعالى
يكاد البرق يخطف ابصارهم كلما اضاء لهم
مشوا فيه واذا اظلم عليهم قاموا بهذه
الايه ضرب الله تعالى المثل للمنافقين
انهم مثل اناس يسيرون في ضوء البرق اذا
اظلم عليهم وقفوا في اماكنهم جاءت قاموا
بمعنى اقاموا واستقروا في مكانهم وليست
بمعنى القيام والنهوض
[موسيقى]
دخل شاعر جاهلي مجلس هارون الرشيد فانشده
قصيده حسنه فاسترابه الرشيد وقال اسمعك
مستحسنا وانكرك متهما يقصد الرشيد ان
القصيده جميله ولكنه في شك من ان يكون هذا
الشاعر الجاهلي قد كتبها بنفسه على الرشيد
فان كنت صاحب هذا الشعر حقا فقل في هذين
واشار الى الامين والمامون وكان جالسين
فقال الشاعر يا امير المؤمنين حملتني على
غير الجدد هيبه الخلافه ووحشه الغربه
وروعه المفاجاه وجلال المقام وصعوبه
البديهه وشرود القوافي على غير الرويه هل
يمهلني امير المؤمنين حتى يتاهل ثنافر
القول وقال الرشيد لا عليك الا تقول قد
جعلت اعتذارك عوضا امتحاني فقال يا امير
المؤمنين نفذت الخناق وسهلت ميدان السباق
ثم انشا قل
بنيت بعبد الله بعد محمد ذرى قبه الاسلام
فاخذ الراعدها هما طنباها بارك الله فيهما
وانت امير المؤمنين عمودها فقال الرشيد
وانت بارك الله فيك سل ولا تكن مسالتك دون
احسانك فقال الهنيده يا امير المؤمنين
امر له بها وبخلع النفيسه وصله جزيلا
والهنيتك ما جاء في لسان العرب هي المئه
من الابل يقول جرير اعطوا هنيده يحدوها
ثمانيه
[موسيقى]
التنور هو الكانون الذي يخبز فيه العجين
او مكان تفجر الماء وردت الكلمه في سوره
هود حتى اذا جاء امرنا وفار التنور يقول
الجواليقي ان الكلمه معربه من الفارسيه
ولا تعرف العرب له اسما غيره هذا اما
السيوطي فيقول ان اصل الكلمه السرياني
ويشير العناسيه لاصل لها في العبراني كما
وردت للاراميه ايضا بلفظه وهو منحوت من
بيت النور
ولعل الصحيح ما قاله ابن عباس من ان الله
مشترك في كثيرا من اللغه
المسك هو طيب وعطر من مصدر حيواني وهي
كلمه معربه من الفارسيه واصلها مشك وقد
وردت الكلمه في كتاب الله تعالى ختامه مسك
وفي ذلك فليتنافس المتنافسون وجاءت ايضا
في شعر الاعشى بعد العتاد ريح المسك اذ
هجمت قبابه
يقول المثل سكت الفا ونطق خلفا فما قصه
هذا المثل
يعود هذا المثل الى الاحنف بن قيس التميمي
احد سادتي بني تميم والذي اسلم في حياه
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم لكنه لم يره
اشتهر الاحنف بحلمه وكان يرى في الصمت
حكمه حتى جالس ذات يوم رجلا يطيل الصمت
فاعجب به وحدثه معتقدا انه حكيم لكن هذا
الرجل حين نطق قال للاحنف يا ابا بحر
اتقدر ان تمشي على شرف المسجد
الا ان تمثل هذا القول سكت الفن ونبقى
خلفا والخلف من القول هو السقط الردي
رب كلمه سلبت نعمه ورب كلمه تقول لصاحبها
دعم
[موسيقى]
تشبه يستعمل العام في بعض الدول العربيه
كلمه تشبص للتعبير عن التمسك بشيء ما او
بفكره
جاء في لسان العرب الشبص الخشونه وتداخل
شوك الشجر بعضه ببعض
ويقال تشبس الشجر
نقذ يقال في بعض العاميات نقز للشخص الذي
اخذته الدهشه والمفاجاه وفي بعض الدول
العربيه يستخدمونها بمعنى الوثوب يقولون
نقز الشخص اذا وثب او قفز او قامه من
مكانه بسرعه وهي كلمه فصيحه وردت في معجم
الوسيط بمعنى وثب صعودا
[موسيقى]
بين الاخر والاخر الاخر بكسر الخاء يعني
خلاف الاول مؤنثه الاخره وجمعه الاواخر
نقول عن الله تعالى هو الاول والاخر
ونقول مشيت من اول الطريق الى اخره بينما
الاخر بفتح الخاء يعني غير ومؤنثه الاخرى
نقول جاء الرجل ومعه رجل اخر اما الشهر
الهجري فهو ربيع الاخر لا ربيع الاخر
[موسيقى]
خرج الحجاج بن يوسف متصيدا مر باعرابيا
فساله كيف سيرته الحجاج فيكم فقال له
الاعرابي ولم يعرف
قال له الحجاج
الى امير المؤمنين عبد الملك فقال
الاعرابي هو والله اظلم منه واغشم فعليه
لعنه رسول الله غضب الحجاج من كلامه فساله
ان تكون اجابه انا الحجاج استعجل الاعرابي
بقوله او تدري من انا قال الحجاج لا قال
مولى بني ثور وجن مرتين في الشهر وهذه
احداهما فضحيك الحجاج وانصرنا
وفي الهجاء ما جربت نفسي ولكن في الهريبه
كالغزال
[موسيقى]
في اوائل الاشياء الصبح اول النهار والغسق
اول الليل والوسمي اول المطر والنبض اول
ما يظهر من ماء البئر اذا حفرت والباكوره
اول الفاكهه والبكر اول الولد
وانها الاول الشرب
والوقت اول الشيب
عن الشيب قال القائل قالت كبرت وشفت قلت
لها هذا غبار وقائع الدهر وعن الوطن
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ماذا تحفظون من
ابيات الشاعر العراقي الراحل عبد الرزاق
عبد الواحد وفيما يلي استعرض معكم بعض ما
وصلني من مشاركاتكم
هذه مشاركه من فيصل الي حبشان يقول لا
تترك الباب تدري انهم رحلوا خذوا المفاتيح
وافتحيها الرجل لا تطرق الباب كانوا حين
تطرقها لا ينزلون اليها كنت تنفعل ويضحكون
وقد تقصوا فتشتموهم وانت في السر مشبوب
الهوى
ومحمد سيدي يقول يذوب القلب يا شنقيط وجدا
عليك لان عندك ما يذيب
وكرامه وسخاء نفس
واعظمهن رفض كما يعيب
وانك بين اوطاني جميعا ملاذ تلتقي فيه
القلوب على حب وليس سواه يبغي ويكرم نفسه
فيك الاديب
مشاركه اخرى من هبه تقول هو العراق وسليل
المجد والحسد هو الذي كل من فيه حفيد نبي
كانما كبرياء الارض اجمعها ثم اليه فما
فيها سواه ابي هو العراق فقل للدائرات في
جاخ الزمان جميعا والعراق وصبي
مشاركه من محاسن تقول كان صوت يناديني
واسمعه يا حارس الدار اهل الدار لم يصلوا
ومشاركه من روان تقول يا صبر ايوب حتى
صبره يصل الى حدود وهذا الصبر لا يصل
اختيارات جميله من شعر الراحل عبد الرزاق
عبد الواحد
الخطاب يقول الحب حب الذين الموت صعد بهم
وعندما قيل صوله باسمه نكفوا فهم يصلون
باسم الحب لا جذعا لكن يد الحب اقوى حين
تنتصف
ومشاركه من احمد يقول لا تعاتب لم تعد
تملك ان تكسر عيني بالعتاب والذي عاتبت لا
يحفل حتى بالجواب
سعد تقول خوفا على قلبك المطعون من المي
سابق الان اوراقي على قلمي
ومشاركه اخيرا من علي يقول وضيعه الارض ان
ضلت شوامخها تهوي ويالو عليها الدوم
والسفر
يعلو بدون الفريق يا علي
بهذه المشاركات الجميله نصل معكم الى كتاب
هذه الفقره اذكركم بانتظره تاملات الجزيره
دائما بعد كل المشاركه
هذا واحد من اعمده الشعر في العراق واذا
اردت ان تصنف فلا ينبغي لك ان تضعه في غير
الطبقه الاولى
دمع لبغداد دمع بالملايين
اللي ببغداد ابكيها
وتبكيني من اللي ببغداد روحي بعدها لبست
وصوت بعدها ابها
سناديني عتبي اليها فقير بعدها وجعي تقيره
احرفي خرسا دواوين
هذه الكلمات وداع المتنبي الاخير كما
يقولون مدينته الاسيره بغداد هو شاعر
القادسيه وعرف ايضا بشاعر القرنين وشاعر
ام المعارك الشاعر العراقي الراحل عبد
الرزاق عبد الواحد الذي يعد واحدا من ابرز
الشعراء العرب العصر الحديث
له اكثر من 40 مجموعه شاريه منشوره فضلا
عن تبوئه لمن عصب ثقافيه مرموقه داخل
العراق وخارجه ونيله جوائز وقد عرف عنه
انه شاعر وطن اذا احب بلاده واخلص لها
فخلدها في قصائده
حديث الشعر بدا عبد الرزاق عبد الواحد
بكتابه الشعر وهو صغير ونشر اول قصيده في
العام
1945 كان حينها في الخامسه عشر من عمره
بعد ذلك ب 50 سنوات وبعد سنه نشر ديوانه
الثاني ثم نشرت النشيد العظيم
واوراق على رصيف الذاكره وخيمه على مشارف
الاربعين ثم الخيمه الثانيه لعام
1975 وصولا الى ديوانه الاخيره يا عراق
يقول الكاتب العراقي احمد الملاح عن شعر
عبد الرزاق عبد الواحد انه قصائده ممتازه
ورصينه ولا يمكن ادراجه الا ضمن عمالقه
الشعر العربي
وصبر ايوب واحده من اعظم قصائده ومن
اكثرها قوه وجزاله في التصوير اضافه الى
قصيده سفر التكوين التي يتحدث فيها
عن العراق
صبر العراق وفي جنبيه مخرزه
يغوص حتى في القلب ينسمل ما قدموا
فاستفزه من محارمه ما اجرامه ما ابادوا
فيهما قتلوا
وطوقهم حوله يمشي مكابره
ومخرز الطوق في احشائه
يغلوا
على مدد وجرحه هو ايضا نازف خبل يا صبر
ايوب حتى صبره الى حدود وهذا الصبر لا يصل
يا صبر ايوب لا ثوب فنخلاعه انضاق عنا ولا
دار
فلنتقل لكنه وطن ادنى مكارمه يا صبر ايوب
انا فيه نكمل وانه غره الاوطان اجمعها
اين عن غرت الاوطان نرتحل
كان الشعر بالنسبه لعبد الرزاق عبد الواحد
حياه باكملها وكان يكتب ان اتاه الوحي
ينقل عنه بحسب بعض مقربي انه قال لقد كتبت
بعض قصائد على وسادتي بسبب نقصان الورق في
فتره من الفترات كان يرى الشعر متجليا في
كل شيء المعاناه التدريب شعرا في بلاده
وصف النص الشعري بانه حاله نفسيه مستمره
ابدا لا تنقطع غير ان اوضاعها متغيره بين
الحزن والفرح وهي تبحث دائما عن ايقاع
موسيقي انسجم معه
في اثناء الدراسه في دار المعلمين
ببغداد رواد الشعر الحر العراقيين الذين
اشتهروا فيما بعد يقول عن تلك الايام كنت
واحدا من مجموعه الشعراء الشباب الاولى
انا ذاكهم السياب ورشيد ياسين واكرم
الوتري ومحمود البريكان وشهد طاقه بلند
الحيدري وكنا نلتقي في مقهى حسن عجمي
ونتعاطى الشعر ونعقد جلسات النقد كتب عبد
الواحد الشعر الحر ايضا لان القصيده
العموديه كانت ملعبه فكتبها بضوابطها
ولغتها
وقوانينها يقول عنه الشاعر العراقي فالح
الجيه في كتابه الموجز في الشهر العربي في
جزء الرابع يقول شعره يشبه شعار المتنبي
في فخره
ويقول انه ذو حنكه شعريه
واسلوب شهريا يميل الى قوه الشاعيريه
والبلاغ
في اواخر ايامه ظهر عبد الرزاق عبد الواحد
على فراش المرض يلقي ابيها تنتسيله حزنا
على فراق العراق
يا عراق هنيئا لمن لا يخونك هنيئا لمن اذ
تكون طاعيا يكونون هنيئا لمن وهو يلفظ اخر
انفاسه
تتلاقى عليه جفونك عبد الرزاق عبد الواحد
غادر العراق
حزينا اسفا بعد الغزو الامريكي
انتقل منها الى سوريا وبعد ذلك ذهب الى
الاردن ثم طار الى باريس التي توفي فيها
في عام 2015 عن امر يناهز 85 عاما وفعامه
بالشعر والحنين وحب الوطن
[موسيقى]
تشرفني يمينك واصطنعني حسام المشهرا في كل
نادي
اخاف من انزلها من اصل مني اذا طال
ارتياحي في الغماد كفحم الارض ان يترك
تردى وان يحصل تجوهر في الكلاب السلام
عليكم
[موسيقى]